hello and welcome to the last talk of
the day it's always a little bit
interesting to be the last figure so I'm
glad to see you haven't gone home
all of you now I've just kind of try to
keep you awake I actually have the
opportunity to to tell you something
that you're going to remember because
you know it's gonna be the last thing
you hear so I'm I'm gonna try to
actually talk a little bit about market
micro services in a way that makes you
think a little bit I've been listening
to Michelle's talk here today and she's
done a couple of talks on micro services
on Dora
and she has a sort of different approach
to it than I have so if any one of you
have listened to those talks I might be
saying things that she would disagree
with and I expect that you would go home
and think about it and maybe make up
your own mind so I will get a small
company I've been doing micro services
and SOA architecture for about ten years
it's a small company in Denmark actually
we do a virtual waiting room that sort
of prevents huge websites or check it
side so all sorts to break and breaking
down when there's a peak in traffic it
doesn't really matter a lot but but I
assume you have all know what at least
have some basic knowledge about what
Naga services are basically you can have
this monolith style of of building your
application and in this case of virtual
waiting room service if you don't sort
of understand what that is just think
Netflix does Netflix streaming stuff and
then you can split it up into these
smaller micro services that you can
deploy and manage individual
so who here is doing some sort of micro
service that's quite a few of you
actually who here would like to do and
you have to be honest yeah so that
combines that's pretty much every one of
you at least ninety percent or so which
is sort of expected there's a lot of
hype around micro services right this is
sort of the new thing and you know all
the cool companies are doing it and they
are promoting it and this is the sort of
awesome line in many ways especially to
developers so I think it's sort of
interesting to explore why we think that
they are so awesome it's even in the
worst that words that we use so we have
a monolith and you have micro services
I'm from Europe and Denmark and we don't
really like anything that is centralised
I mean no big or anything I can have an
argument with my bosses he's gonna he's
gonna give me a race right so we like
decentralized things so so even before
we sort of start about start talking
about what they are about then we
already have some sort of opinion about
it so in this case here is pretty much
the same as talking about the testa and
the rebel fleet who do we like I think
that's that's one reason why it's so
interesting and other reason is that
we've all tried this layered
architecture and what you know over time
in the beginning it's sort of nice is
layered and you can reason about it and
understand what happens when you change
something and eventually you know you're
gonna have these dependencies across
your application and so when you change
something here it's something it's going
to blow up over here I think we have all
had that experience at least a lot of us
and sort of microservices promises to
make these smaller independent units
that you sort of don't have that issue
even so even if you have some sort of
really
nicely layered architecture and you
don't have these dependencies across
your lanes here you're still gonna have
a database that is shared amongst
everybody so you're still gonna do nasty
things to the database acquiring data
that you know doesn't really belong to
that part of the application another
reason is that we as developers I don't
know how many out there all of us but I
am we like complexity not the kind of
complexity will that we just talked
about but the sort of technical
technology complexity your tools and
frameworks and services and sine
patterns and and so of complexity that's
what we sort of think is funny about the
work we did the same thing a thing every
day we sort of report also it makes us
you know go to these sort of conferences
where we learn new stuff right and we
also love to talk about new technology
here right it's the more complex it is
you know interesting it is so we sort of
drawn to this complexity and
micro-services has a lot of complexity I
mean there's a lot of dimensions that
are added the old technology scope in
micro-services but I think you know for
me mostly it's the promises of these
decoupled and independent services and
all my professional career I've been
taught that we should you know minimize
dependencies between our software
modules in there that we do we have to
have the high cohesion rife and
decoupled modules so this is something
that we've been learnt that we need and
it's actually a very nice promise and it
does also fulfill that promise if you do
it right so this is you know go for it
let's just do it is sort of awesome
right what we sort of sometimes forget
to think about is
is this actually valuable to us we have
been in his hype anything is everything
is awesome and great but is it valuable
and I'm not sort of thinking about a
from technical perspective because you
can always argue that you know the tools
and the disciplines we use in micro
services they are valuable but
translating that into some business
value this is a little bit more
difficult
we should also explain explore what the
trade offs are because there are a lot
of trade offs and again also pitfalls so
what can go wrong while we're doing this
so is it valuable now if you need to
sort of answer that question we need to
know what is the value that Microsoft
microservices spring and when we start
to explore that you know it sort of
becomes apparent that it's not a
technical one that is the primary reason
why we do micro services it's a people
one ok micro services come from you know
companies like Netflix or Airbnb or all
the big ones that have thousands of
employees and they have a people problem
they need to figure out how to get
thousands of people to work on the same
product so the reeds of the sort of
solution for this is all of course these
cross-functional teams that are
individual and you know that can take it
you know tasks and deliver on that task
by themselves without having any sort of
dependencies of dependencies on other
teams and that is really what micro
services allow so all the things the
technical solutions we have to this
problem is mostly about scaling the
organization
so once we know that I mean I don't
think a lot of us are working with
Netflix or a company in that size so
what if we a smaller team can really
benefit from doing micro services yes
probably but I think you would need to
have some special requirements so for
instance for us we are like twelve
people on the development team but we
have some very unique or not unique but
at least quite advanced and quite
serious problems with scaling and
availability so for us it makes sense to
actually have an micro service
architecture when you have that
architecture is so much easier to scale
because typically you don't need to
scale the entire application you just
sort of need to scale the corner of it
so if you have small services that just
sort of serve that corner then it's
easier to scale it same goes for
availability and reliability so we can't
be down so low that that's that's not an
option to do that because we sort of
live from being available when our
customers are down so it's easier to
build and available and reliable system
if you have micro services then there
can be other requirements like
technology so do you need to use
different types of programming languages
C for instance to do something very
performance ladies programs before where
you don't want to write everything in C
so you sort of have requirements for for
using multiple programming languages
which is maybe you have different data
stores underneath okay so maybe you
don't have any of these requirements so
can you still benefit from doing a micro
services architecture you know probably
not I would say but there are a lot of
disciplines and sort of ideas around
micro services that you definitely can
improve you sure
your application so what are these
trade-offs you keep talking about I've
been at a number of these conferences
here and there are a lot of speakers
right we talk about what you should and
should not do don't really talk about
what the trade-offs are and they're kind
of a lot of them so most of them around
the deployment the operation and the
testing also the development and the
operation and the test and debug
monitoring areas so as a developer you
have to sort of all of a sudden there's
a lot of different practices as usual
sudden have to do that you didn't have
to do before or at least you have to do
it in a smaller scale you have any
number of repositories like I might have
a twenty five or a hundred or thousand
repositories all of sudden all of these
had projects you need to create build
and deployment pipelines for them it
might be in different languages so this
is not just copy-paste thing is you can
use the same template for everything you
have installation script you need to
bootstrap some of the servers maybe and
because of this the sort of the the size
and the scale of it it's really really
important that you sort of get it very
very detailed so the deployment pipeline
for instance it's not about just having
a continuous integration server that
runs some unit tests you sort of have to
go all the way so that you can you can
test and deploy your systems with very
few click of a button or or something
like that so there's a lot of time and
effort that goes into actually building
this and so will win speakers and blog
posts and whatever you read sort of
describe this they will say something
like what I have to sit here you have to
do it right
but it takes a lot of time if you only a
few people it's just very difficult to
actually get some business value out of
it
there are things the developer needs to
take care of we all of sudden have a
very advanced Network layer that we need
to deal with so we have api's and DTS
and civilization and rest and
asynchronous messaging which is really
important and on top of that you have to
deal with all kinds of new error
scenarios in the i/o and with latency
and arrows so the latency small latency
in one service can actually have a huge
impact on a service in a different part
of the application so that's a lot to
deal with you again multiple programming
languages you have frameworks and tools
to sort of support all this complexity
that is sort of added to your process
you have multiple services and data
stores that needs to be used so there's
a lot of things to learn and a lot of
things to master all of a sudden if you
sort of want to reach the full potential
anyway then there's debugging debugging
is not as easy anymore you sort of used
to be able to debug a new IDE now you
have to sort of set everything up either
on your local machine now you have to do
it somewhere in the cloud maybe you
don't have a full stack trace of what's
going on so debugging becomes a bit more
complicated than it was before
you have versioning so because you have
these individual teams you're releasing
a version of your API you can't just you
know tell all the teams to go and update
that version so you will always have at
least at least one of course but
probably multiple versions of your API
that you need to support you have
availability and redundancy
I'm gonna go into that a little bit
deeper later but that's sort of things
you need to worry about as well that
maybe you didn't have to worry about so
much before in the monolith then you
have operations again this is there you
go this is mostly a factor of the
multiple services now your operations
team if you have one of those they don't
they can't just monitor one service
anymore
they have multiple services that they
need to have that they need to manage in
the system they have multiple they have
new technologies as well you're likely
to use some cloud technology or some
container technology to make this work
the operations team will need to be able
to support this as well then there's a
lot more error cases for the operation
team so there's a whole new I said this
whole new layer of network that they
need to be able to respond to and these
errors here they've sort of caused these
strange error cases deeper down the
system if there's for instance if
there's just a little bit of latency you
can cause some very serious problems
somewhere else in the system so
troubleshooting also becomes very more
much more painful you have to know a lot
more about the system than you had
before in order to be effective in this
then there's monitoring you're not
managing one service
you're also mind you monitoring hundred
services you're also managing network
all kinds of things that you need to to
look into locking simple thing right
usually a lot to some drive somewhere
and then you can maybe import it into
some tool now we have a hundred services
running somewhere and some talk of
things you need to get this logging data
into some centralized storage you have
distributed tracing so if you have any
transaction like an order
that transaction is bound to go through
multiple services so just getting the
logs correlated to each other is the
thing that you didn't have to think
about before so again the the extra load
on the operations team will probably
mean that you need to transition
transition into this DevOps principles
instead so you can actually get your
developers to be operational people or
at least hire someone that can pose to
development and operation and that's
simply because there you have all these
new error scenarios so just handing your
code on to the operation team is
becoming more difficult then there's
tests and debugging I said a little bit
about debugging right but you have these
multiple services you can't just hit f5
maybe you need maybe you can't actually
host the entire application on your your
own device on your own computer so you
might need environments to to support
this in either case whether you do it on
your own laptop on some test environment
somewhere it's going to be complex so
but just setting this up and managing it
and you know preparing data for which
and running tests and all that it's just
a lot more painful yeah
another part of testing is that unit
tests they don't really have as much
value anymore because all of your code
is sort of spread across multiple
services so you need to some do
something else you need to have a higher
focus on doing integrations test
integration test sort of brittle they
fail due to various reason and they are
actually harder to implement so that'll
take you more time to do you might even
need to introduce some new principles
layering some new practices like chaos
engineering it's pretty cool well what
but it does actually the thing is that
if you have a microscope or conjecture
you have these areas in our scenarios
that are so hard to predict right yeah
again with the network you know you have
multiple different data stores so maybe
you know if one of them goes down does
your entire application go down so chaos
engineering is this way of exposing
these errors before they happen the same
thing with site reliability engineering
so we have all these new practices that
you sort of have to at least think about
so pitfalls so what can go wrong here
Michelle talked a little bit little bit
about pitfalls as well it's really easy
to build a system a microservice system
that is worse than what you had before
now so many things that can go wrong and
along the way especially if you do not
have any skilled people on your team so
if you try to do micro services with a
couple of junior developers and the
offshore development team or something
it's likely that you're gonna get hurt
even with skilled people I would say you
would need to practice it's not
something that you sort of just jump
into and then think that everything is
going to go well
I'm gonna come back to the practice part
a little bit later on but yeah really
important also if you sort of start on
the path of having multiple programming
languages and multiple services actually
doing this one of the benefits of
micro-services is that you can sort of
pick the right tool for the job but when
you do that you just require more of
your developer development team so
that's important to realize that and
only hire some skilled people right so
be aware of the distributive monolith as
a cool world word distributed monolith
so the distributed monolith is the
situation where you have dependencies
between your services they're supposed
to be independent but you end up in a
situation where they are actually
dependent on each other and when they
are dependent on each other then the
team's also dependent on each other and
then you sort of lose the the ability to
scale the organization so this can for
example be that you have a shared model
across your services you have a database
across your services so basically if you
change something in the data structure
then you would need to change the model
in all of the services also let's say
you do have a micro service in front of
it you're the team for the micro service
has actually been kind enough to make an
SDK that the other teams can use to call
the micro service let's then say there's
a business requirement and the team sort
of chooses to put in this feature this
performance of optimization or whatever
it is in the SDK then that is SDK is to
be distributed to 20 other teams that
puts it into 50 other services
and now there's an actually in an error
in there a critical error in this SDK so
what do you do you have to go out to 20
different different teams and get them
to update 50 different applications with
this SDK so you have a very tight
coupling even though you actually made a
micro service so these are things to be
aware of especially if you need to scale
the organization don't have these
dependencies this is really also comes
down to this don't repeat yourself
principles that we've been taught for
the last 30 years or 40 years Microsoft
microservices is sort of an indirect
conflict with that if you put shared
code in some library that everybody
depends on then you have a dependency
between the teams so I'm not saying that
you shouldn't do it but sometimes it's
just better to actually copy the code
than it is to to to share it in a shared
library and that goes sort of against
everything we been taught
so Michelle if you saw the previous talk
and the one before that and the one
before that talks a lot about eventually
consistency and this is extremely
important so the way you decoupling
services is by using messaging instead
of actually having a RDP call to other
services like West or similar then you
need to do an asynchronous way as much
as possible let's say you have an order
and that order goes into the order
system then there's a fulfillment system
you don't need to actually send the rest
message to this fulfillment system
because now you have a tight coupling
between those two system if the
fulfillment system is not available for
whatever reason then you order will fail
instead if you check that's command you
have for two familiar filmin system and
put it in a message and a message queue
or message broker or whatever we should
call it then the fulfillment service can
pick up that's that message and do what
it needs to do whenever it is available
so this is also a way of both a way of
decoupling the systems but also a way of
actually making them available so very
important if you need to embrace this
and this is sort of probably the
discussion most teams have if this
eventually consistency is really a good
idea but if you want to succeed with
micro services you have to do it there's
sort of no way around it
and even you know it's sort of imposed
on you in any way because if you're in
the cloud or if you're using a no sequel
database or any other service almost
except for a relational database then
you have eventually consistency anyway
okay so here's one of the tough ones the
organization may need to change so if
you are sort of in a traditional
organization you will have some database
experts sitting over here in a silo
you'll have operations team you'll have
some front-end guys you'll have some
back-end guys and different silos if you
want the organization's to scale then
these guys needs to talk together and
the more people needs that needs to talk
together across these boundaries the
more dependencies Europe so this is the
part about having these cross-functional
teams that is sort of the base success
of the base reason for success of
Netflix and and the other big
corporations so this is difficult to do
I mean especially if you are in a large
company I'm lucky enough to be in a
start-up so we sort of did this from the
beginning
oops another one that is really
important and it's really tricky this is
the part about bounded context and
domains so bounded context is the way
that we should separate the services
from each other we shall talk about it
the last time so last talk here but for
those of you that didn't hear it is
trying to find these natural boundaries
in your organization so you might have a
subscription part of your organization
you might have a billing and you might
have a Identity Management these are
sort of natural boundaries within your
organization and in your system so this
is where we want to to split the micro
services now the tricky part about this
is that if you sort of starting on a
project you don't really know your
domain like for instance where I work we
have this virtual waiting room and we
thought in the beginning
you know eight years ago that this
service should be available to anyone it
should be a sort of a free service that
everybody can install on their websites
it took us like five four or five years
to figure out that this product is
actually mostly interesting to huge
corporations and that sort of changed
the entire domain of what we were doing
we thought we should do social media
integration and that sort of stuff but
what the corporation's wanted was
reporting and it was you know security
and all that stuff so the point is here
that refactoring a micro services one
micro service is easy its small and you
can actually just throw it away
build a new one pretty easily but if you
want to refactor between these
boundaries between micro services you
all of a sudden have a huge problem
because you have the contracts between
these services that needs to be changed
you have data models that needs to be
changed everything just gets really
really complex and so the problem is
that you cannot really define these
boundaries until you know your domain
and at that time if you already have so
settled on a micro service architecture
then it's too late because you like to
likely to mist it up so I'm gonna
probably talk a little bit more about
that as well
but it's really really important before
you begin you sit down and you learn
these things and look for DDD this
winter and design these concepts are
found mainly in design and they have
practices to sort of explore your domain
by using these domain events and
figuring out what what aggregates they
belong to and so forth
okay here's another one that can get
interesting availability and reliability
so it's it's fairly easy to have a model
with with the reasonable availability so
if you want to go for one nine or two
nines you can sort of do that in a
monolith the thing is if you separate
that bottom monolith into let's say for
critical services that each have you
know reasonable availability in this
case the one with the worst availability
is 99.3%
then you should think that you know this
application is as good as the weakest
link so the availability must be 99.3%
in fact there's a little bit math to it
but in fact it's it's a function of the
phone so you're gonna end up with a
availability which is much lower so this
is the reason why you sort of need to
think about how to availability and
reliability when you do a micro service
architecture and then of course ways of
working on this by using these misses
message passing and also doing we don't
in senior services of course and if you
do that it's possible to get a system
that is very reliable and very available
but if you don't think about it it's
probably gonna be worse than what you
have okay so what are you thinking about
micro services now still like it ah I
think they're amazing
you just definitely go for it just start
flying there are a lot a lot of good
things about micro services and
especially the practices that sort of
make up my services for me micro
services are sort of just some things
that we already knew you like having
this low coupling and
doing things that are sort of individual
does one thing really really good these
are things that we sort of known for
many many years there's nothing new to
that
what sort of is new that we have some
tools and we have some some frameworks
and some infrastructure like in the
cloud or talker or whatever yeah open
source tools that sort of support this
all of a sudden so it's sort of feasible
to do it
so despite of all this it might still be
a good idea to do it even though you're
a small team the sort of sort of way
it's it's a little bit I'm a little bit
two-faced on this is that all the
speakers I've ever heard about magazines
is sort of educators on that we there's
a lot of things that we cannot do we
have to do things in a certain way we
have to be aware of a lot of things and
we have to do everything right and all
of these things that are just so sure
showed you they just take a lot of time
and it's time you take away from
actually providing business value so for
me you know it's sort of about
imperfection right so most of us are not
Netflix if you were Netflix you would
have to do everything by the book and
you would actually also gain from that
because you would be able to realize the
potential that Microsoft microservices
promises because you have this large
organization you have scaling issues you
have the whole thing you need to be
reliable you know if on the other hand
if you were just one person you know
you're probably not you know going to
build any system at all because you're
gonna spend all your time on and all the
technical part of it most of us are sort
of in between somewhere right whether we
are ten developers of 20 or 50 on a
given product project we're sort of in
between
where we can realize the full potential
then we can still benefit from some of
it right this is sort of a little bit
you know again developers when we sort
of see something that is imperfect
that's not great it's sort of tend to
sit down and refactor right it's like my
my girlfriend at home at home she's sort
of vacuuming vacuuming the house like
twice a day or something and you know
sometimes you know I want to make her
happy so I vacuumed the floor before she
gets home and the first thing she does
when she gets home we start vacuuming
right so this is this sort of perfection
thing everything needs to be really
really perfect and I'm sure you sort of
had this experience before where you
look at some code you wrote maybe a year
ago or someone else wrote and you take
what the hell is this I need to I need
to refactor right I'm gonna sit down
five hours refactoring this because it
looks like yeah and you know it doesn't
provide any business value at all but
you know have to do it and I'm not
saying that's necessarily a bad thing
because we would like to keep on cool
clean and we would like to you know meet
our standards but at some point right
the value of doing it doesn't really
make sense compared to the effort that
we put into it I think that's very key
to my the services you sort of have to
make some you know decisions about what
is it that you would like to focus on
what is the parts of micro services that
make sense in your context who likes
scrum there's a couple of people like
scrum there's a couple of things that I
don't like about what's gone right one
of the things is that they you can hire
this consultant who comes out and he
says something like
maybe it's called an agile coach or
something but what he's going to say is
that I can create this hyper productive
teams for you it's like times three of
what you normally see the only thing you
have to do is to not deviate from scrum
maybe not the only thing but you don't
deviate from strong right now that sort
of stops my build stuff you know that's
wrong it's not putting things into
context just putting things down you
know dragging things over principles
over some organization will not make it
better just because it's some book
lesson the same thing I feel about my
services then we have this term here
monolith first and it is actually built
a monolith first and you're going he's
crazy you want me to build a monolith
just to split up into microservices yes
I guess that's what I'm saying and this
is for reasons that I sort of already
spoke a little bit about the the thing
about the bounded context and the domain
if you don't know the domain you're
likely to get it wrong and once you get
it wrong you have to refactor it that's
expensive so you sort of pay the expense
anyway even though it's not a monolith
you have to refactor it into something
that you didn't think it should be
secondly you mean at least if you are
start-up or in many cases you built this
MVP you write the Minimum Viable Product
and the purpose of this first version of
your system is actually to learn right
you need to build the minimum thing that
makes value that gives value to your end
users while you're still well you can
learn stuff from it if you have to do
all of the things
that I just showed you on these slides
would that be a minimal Viable Product
no I mean you wouldn't learn anything
from shipping your logs to some
centralized log stories not about the
business anyway
wouldn't it doesn't bring any value to
the end-user you wouldn't learn anything
from it whether you wouldn't you would
learn something from it but you wouldn't
learn whether the users would actually
love the product that you're building so
you might in spending a lot of time
doing all these things that required by
micro services just to find out you know
that nobody wants to use your product so
the idea here and actually this is not
something I have come up with you can go
to Martin Fowler's website and blog and
he will say the same thing and actually
you know all the stories you hear from
Airbnb and Netflix they all started with
a monolith that they broke up and yes
that takes time
you know take years to do and it's
probably difficult because you've
already made this mess that I showed you
with the dependencies so we need to
straighten that out you need to
introduce all kinds of things it takes a
long time but the good thing about that
is that you get to practice because this
is not easy to do you have to sort of
have these skilled people and while
you're doing this you're actually
practicing doing it so the way you could
do it is to start picking out pieces of
this monolith you have for instance
identify places where it hurts these
places are typically the ones that have
multiple dependencies so if you have the
patent seized throughout your system to
some module it could be for instance of
reporting module that everybody wants to
send data to then that will probably
start hurting a bit now you could take
that out put it into a separate service
the good thing now is you know we
abounded context you know you domain so
you can do that and you have a fairly
high certainty that you know you don't
have to redo it
you can also look for key services like
for instance the Identity Management
Service now if you pull that out into a
separate services service it might be a
lot easier to do some of the other
services because you have aggregates in
place and you have messaging around
that's very central piece of of code
that will help you when your soul up
start some of the other areas if you
want to practice you can look for
low-risk good candidate data it could be
some report that you generate in some
let's say web server who done that I
have trouble fields on that you sort of
probably know that's having this
long-running process of building PDFs
and maybe even integrating with Word or
some craziest thing like that in a web
server that's not a good idea because
all the threats and technologies it's
just not built for that so that would be
a good you know thank you to identifying
also it might not be very may or may not
be but there's a chance that it's sort
of a low-risk thing if it doesn't work
for half an hour or something then you
know people will get their report
eventually and then of course if you
have new requirements so let's say
something changes dramatically in your
requirements then rather than changing
it in the monolith you can just build a
new one once that's sort of built then
switch your monolith to use use that one
instead I'm sure there are other ways of
doing it so again it's context thing
what you would like to do
yeah so another thing you could do if
you don't want to sort of go into a
full-blown microservice architecture and
you're not you know in you know it's
sort of a great big team then you could
look for these bounded contexts and
think them into your architecture so we
had this one yeah I talked about it a
couple of times what we sort of usually
do here when we have this situation of
these dependencies across the entire
application is we sort of introduce a
new layer right so we're gonna put in a
new layer that is sort of abstract some
of this away and makes you know what
layers really do is just for humans to
reason about the code view er doesn't
care about layers it's just for us so we
can talk about it and we can understand
the code so we put in more and more
layers and I don't know if anyone of you
have tried it but at least I have yeah
or at least my boss has so my boss will
come up to someone one of the developers
and say something like hey can you add
this field to the database and just make
a simple input box in the UI and then
flow the data into it yes I can do that
all take me three days because I need to
translate between details and models and
make unit tests for that and do all
kinds of stuff and layers and what do I
know
so if just instead think this bounded
context take these boundaries context
into the architecture then you can
actually make it an architecture that's
much more clean so what you do is you
take away all these you sort of think
about what areas of my applications to
do I have like maybe have a product card
catalog maybe I have a card an order
system
Phil menses fulfillment system and user
management or whatever just like you
would do with microservices and then you
separate your application is still the
same one application is still a monolith
it's still running in one process maybe
your few processes but the point here is
that the communication between these
boundaries gets to be very defined you
have this contract first idea and so you
create a contract to be able to
communicate between the different parts
of the application so all of a sudden
it's much more clean how your
architecture is is created now is still
old and you can do this in the same
application you could do it as
namespaces or modules or whatever you
would like to do as long as you sort of
have these rules and you apply the rules
of course that you cannot do
communication between the different
between in different contexts except for
the the API that you have defined so if
at some point you decide ok this
particular part of the application like
reporting or whatever it is you would
like to pull that out into a separate
service that once on a separate Hardware
a separate process then it's pretty easy
to do that because all you have to do is
to change the the API that was once in
process to something that is out of
process a message queue or whatever and
then take the code and put it into a
separate service and make sure it's
deployed somewhere
that point about doing this is of course
that while you have everything in
process you sort of don't have all the
trade offs that I talked about you don't
need to worry about blogging in the same
way you don't even need to worry about
you know debugging and testing you can
still have your sort of unit search that
runs across maybe even cross the
boundaries so it's a lot more easy you
don't get the pain or not the pain
because we love all the technology and
all the trade all the decisions that we
need to do but you don't get that
complexity and you're able to actually
focus what really matters for the
business while you still have a clean
architecture that is easy to reason
about
all right
so what are sort of the minimum
requirements to get started on this so I
would say there's a couple of things
that you need to get if you wanted to
micro services and I think you should if
you have the requirements for it then
there's a couple of things that you need
to take care of one of them we talked
about it already you need to have a
decent deployment pipeline so continuous
delivery of some kind it doesn't have to
be perfect but you're at least you need
to be able to deploy your services in a
predictable manner and it should be
something that is done fairly quickly so
you can use it for your test
environments and there's sort of no one
we wait to do this but it just takes
time I mean it takes longer than you
expect it sounds really really nice with
all the slides with you seen today
probably of how you should do this and
you can build docker images in your CI
and sort of go to repository and you can
magically appear somewhere but it's just
not in practice it takes longer right
but it's also really really important
that you have it up front because if you
don't do it you're going to spend a lot
more time on things that should have
been automated in the first place so
definitely recommendation if you need to
spend a week doing this when you start
and you should spend a week on that
because the time will be repaid
afterwards yep development environments
there's a bit back and forth and that
should you have everything locally on
your box so you can deeper maybe you
want to do that in the beginning of the
product rather than the project but
eventually I think you will find that
it's not sort of a scalable way of doing
it so I'll recommend that you have
separate environments that are available
for development that users can
you're developers developers you can use
su Deepak and you test and and that's
one and one of the reasons is that
especially if you're in the cloud is
that some of the services that you might
use like so are we on AVS so that would
be dynamo or it would be an S or any or
whatever it is many of those services
don't actually have a proxy or something
that you can install locally so you sort
of need to use the ones on the real
production one a lot the production ones
but the ones running in uh Navy s so
actually running everything locally is
not possible to do unless you sort of
spend a lot of time on time on creating
stops for it which I don't think make
any sense so you're sort of forced to to
do that it's but again it's it's
something that is up for discussion of
course whether they should do one of the
other it's totally depends on the
context for us we just so invested in
Amazon and all the services that it's
just not possible to do so automate
automate this stuff make sure it's
available for developers to use
otherwise your velocity will just drop
then there's logging and monitoring this
sort of thing should really be in place
until you go before you go into
production right at least some basic
some basic parts of it I think what we
do is that you know monitoring is really
a part of the definition you've done so
I said I didn't like scrum but
definitely not done it's probably a good
thing
so before something can be deployed to
production you should make sure that we
have all the monitoring and alerts and
an escalation on that again logging make
sure that your locks are sent to some
centralized storage there are lots and
lots and lots of services out there that
can do it for decent amount of money
don't have to sort of build it yourself
in fact I'm not sure why you would build
it yourself send it to Lockley or
whatever service you would like to do
use they do a lot better job at it
I'm sure unless you're a sort of a huge
organization that have people do it
anyway
really really important if you don't
have this sort of in place as I said
there's all these error scenarios that
can sort of pop up and will pop up but
you didn't imagine would be there so if
you don't have some system that can
actually revert you on this and maybe
even self heal then you're sort of in
problem so here's the thing that is I
think also important
juicing technology it's also always fun
right the thing is that the choices you
make and technology will have a huge
impact on the amount of work you need to
do on these you know things that sort of
part of micro services so if you're if
you don't have an Operations team with
sort of experience with docker or
similar technology then and you're not
in a cloud then you should probably
think about not doing microsomes
I mean the cloud or toggle and these
tools here will just help you enormously
they will provide a lot of these
different things that you need in order
to automate optimize things so we have a
principle that says something like when
we need to develop a new service we will
look at it and see ok can we run this
service again we are this small team so
if we need to spend a lot of time I'm
actually running our software then we
don't have time for doing business value
so if you sort of deploy things service
you get a lot of things for free scaling
and availability and logging and all
these things you
least a lot of these things even
deployment is something that is sort of
easier or out-of-the-box if we can't do
service then the next choice should be a
container of some kind and this I mean
again if you a small company like us
it's sort of difficult because dargah is
this huge critical piece of acknowledged
e if you have to run that on your own
it requires some serious skills now
luckily the last year or so or two the
cloud has been an abs and Microsoft had
been really great at releasing new
services that makes it easy so an abs at
least you have Fargate and basically
here now all you need to do is create
your image ship it to my abs and they
will make sure that it's deployed on
some cluster somewhere that you don't
really care about or maybe not care
about takes a lot away a lot of
complexity then the next thing we do so
we can deploy it on service and not on
talking then there's some serious reason
why it should go on an ec2 instance or
even a dedicated instance it might be
worth actually thinking about how can we
change our application so that we can
deploy it into to to service so talkin
when you sort of deploy it on a virtual
instance you get a lot of the complexity
that you need to handle yourself so a
vyas will of course help you with some
of the things Oh
Microsoft Asia will help with some of
the things but you will let a lot of
things are left and you need to deal
with such as auto scaling they might
help you but you still need to sort of
create an application that can all scale
really
bootstrap itself you need to sort of get
the data the the binaries and the
configuration from some repository
somewhere and then make sure that it's
installed on the server and you need to
patch the OS and all that stuff it just
takes time and it takes time away from
doing something that is valuable to the
business so and so if you want to - so
one of the things that Michelle talked
about just in the previous talk was that
you have to convince the business that
this is a good idea so if you start
spending a lot of time on doing all
these things that doesn't provide any
business value and the business cannot
see that they're getting any value from
the time that it spent then there's
probably gonna shut it down if you
choose service for instance you can
quite easily get running in a very short
time and that's sort of a way of showing
the business that okay here's the value
that we've provided in a very short time
and you might you know actually she sit
on it technology is more than just the
infrastructure of course it's also
programming languages and services and
open source frameworks and whatever it
might be a good idea to sort of in the
beginning while you're learning actually
just restricting it a little bit so
saying you know we'll start with these
services you'll learn them and then you
know as we practice and get better we'll
get attract more things into this way
whatever makes sense we add the points
of where we we've been for a while where
we say anything that Amazon has built
we're gonna use if it fits in and that
just increases velocity by you know a
factor of three or something but it does
require that you're sort of ready for it
again also the programming languages
it's sort of very tempting to say okay
I would like to use Skylar for this
particular problem here but if you know
you only have one person that knows
Skylar or two then might not be a good
idea because what if they leave then you
have a development team that sort of
sits with a service that they cannot
maintain there are sort of multiple
aspects into this obviously if you're a
larger team
multiple teams then you know it's tall
starts to make sense
because you can sort of maybe utilize
let's say developers that know PSP for
something and all the developers that
you know see for something else yeah and
then one of the big you know important
things to to have when you get started
is to have some asynchronous messaging
technology available to you the risk is
sort of that you fall into this we'll
just we'll just do rest and everything
and one of the things that sort of made
is a way may go bad was that we had Web
Services so we did remote procedure
calls RPC to actually invoke how
services so they became very tightly
coupled now rest is also an RPC there's
no real distinction between how there is
of course a distinction but basically
you know web services and rest or sort
of the same thing it's still synchronous
calls made so if you don't have this
from the beginning you sort of risk
having a very brave old system at the
end because it might never introduce it
right you just get accustomed to do this
wrist everything you do between these
boundaries of the services the bounded
context you should try to do it in an
asynchronous manner
so again bounded context call domain I
talked about bounded context but
basically the core domain in your if you
know DDD there's the core domain
different subdomains so the core sub
domain and then they have you know
supporting subdomains and you have
generic subdomains oh the core domain is
where you make your money right
supporting domains could be you know
things that sort of it's not doesn't
really distinguish you from from your
competitors or other companies but they
are sort of necessary for your service
to work and then you have supporting
things like supporting so domains like
your support functionality that's just
something that you want to pull out of
them you maybe want to buy right like
locking repositories could be an example
so the point here is and it's also the
point in DDD is that you don't apply TDD
to all of your subdomains you apply them
where they actually give value and and
that's because TDD is difficult requires
this it has the same problem as problems
that microservices have requires skilled
people and because you know time it's
just hard to do so you apply it with you
know brings value and I think the same
is the case for micro services there's
no reason why you would build everything
in micro services you might have some
part of your core domain or the core
domain that you do it this way and all
the parts of your application that does
it in a more monolithic version
so if you take anyway anything away from
this talk I think you should go buy a
book on domain-driven design and read it
understand the concepts even if you're
not you know doing TDD or you're not
doing micro services there are still a
lot of principles in there that are
really really helpful to know yep
enjoy I would say I think they are
awesome I mean you get a lot of benefits
from doing micro services there are some
pains you can reduce them luckily when
we started the seven eight years ago
there wasn't really a lot of tooling for
this the cloud providers didn't really
have any functionality that supported
micro services nowadays you have darker
you have auto scaling you have server
lists you have a lot of different things
that makes it really really at least
easier and the benefits that you sort of
get from micro services are easier to
gain so I think I mean if you have some
of the requirements that are sort of
matching the benefits of micro services
it doesn't have to be the scale of the
organization definitely if you have that
market service this is a good thing but
even if you don't I mean there are still
things that you can take away from micro
services you probably don't want to
implement everything we certainly
haven't done that one of the things is
that we still have a shared model across
some of our services and you go like
dude that's that's wrong right everybody
will say that's wrong I even said it
before it's a distributive monolith but
we sort of have the situation where we
our model is quite simple there's not a
lot to it really and it doesn't really
change the lot and we're a small team so
having a shared model and shared data
layer across all services actually makes
our velocity
much faster because we don't have to
deal with a lot of network traffic and
civilization and all that stuff
as we grow it starts to be painful we
get you know into situations where you
know we have these dependencies across
services there's some error or some
model that needs to change and you sort
of have to change in multiple places and
you have to deploy then you have sort of
have to deploy everything as a whole or
you have to somehow if it's a critical
service that needs to run all the time
you have to do it in steps right you
change the model and deploy it and then
you have to change the more you remove
the old stuff and deploy it and so we
have this multi-step thing and it just
takes you know a week to do this those
are the sort of the dependencies you
don't want to have and when you start
hurting your refactor right you start
separating the data layer into smaller
models that fits the services you have
so you know this thing about
imperfection I think it's really really
important unless you are in fact Netflix
and yeah it's amazing
go for it thank you I don't know if I'm
on time or anything
hope you had to go to conference